قد يكون طاهٍ هاو نشر مقاطع فيديو
لنفسه وهو يطبخ على موقع يوتيوب قد
أعطى
أكثر من وصفات تقول الشرطة الإيطالية إن
مارك
فيران كلود بيرد هو
هارب مزعوم وبحسب الشرطة الإيطالية
كان متورطًا في تهريب المخدرات
بين
هولندا وإيطاليا ، قال مسؤول إيطالي إن
بيورك  هو أحد أخطر
الهاربين الذين ينتمون
إلى indragata ، وهي نقابة
قوية يعتقد أنها مسؤولة عن
حوالي 80 في المائة من الكوكايين الذي
يدخل أوروبا
على مدار السنوات الخمس الماضية أو نحو ذلك ،
عاش bjart حياة هادئة باستثناء
هواية نشرها  فيديوهات له
وزوجته يطبخان
على اليوتيوب في الفيديوهات التي لا
تشاهدان فيها وجه بيارد ولكن يمكنك أن تبرز بعضًا
من الأوشام المميزة التي يقولها رجال الشرطة
والتي دفعتهم
إلى إلقاء اللحية واعتقاله ،
تم إرسال جارت إلى إيطاليا يوم الاثنين
إلى  يواجهون
بعضًا من تلك التهم بتهمة الاتجار بالمخدرات
المزعومة لم تتمكن CNN من الوصول إلى أي من محامي الفنون
في الشرطة الإيطالية يقولون أنه منذ
bjart  كان هاربًا وأنه
ربما كان قادرًا على
البقاء مختبئًا لولا شغفه
بالطبخ الإيطالي الذي شاركه مع العالم
باتريك جوتمان سي إن
هافانا